[Music]
in sooner than you think news was that
Scottish sooner than you think cloudy
hoping in the [ __ ] Asya I love it when
you do it right sorry
sooner than you think news submitted by
logical chaos but scientists have
determined how long it takes with people
to decide to marry someone to marry some
know they already know I could do that
[Laughter]
he's like what do you call those the
bogans countries they all Tennessee
anyway you're really good
oh thank you oh I love that have
determined how long it takes for me for
people to decide to get married I always
I always wonder about these types of
studies because they're so not
quantitative cuz how like how do you
measure that like I saw this other study
I'm sorry it's not related man there was
a lot the attractiveness of Asian men
and how like it was like Oh for an Asian
man to be seen as equal to a wife it was
a professor with that professor who was
like he has to make two hundred thousand
dollars more than the and I was just
like how do I get that a study was made
but what I qualified yeah what tests
poop what dating site like how big yeah
exactly how we got into some no and it
was dope cuz then you know like yeah I
respond to you and then like you know we
got a little our conversation was cool
like it got promoted and [ __ ] but yeah
how do you in the first place like where
does he get that information it's like
okay I get that there was a study but
but in most social studies right it's so
easy to
change it with your statistics change
your variable I know some bomb-ass Asian
dudes that could nab some hotties and
there's some dog ass [ __ ] dude
they make nothing and it mooch off all
their girls dude I don't know how they
do it it's amazing
they're that good-looking no they're not
they're disgusting but their game is
just so good yeah they just come up with
[Laughter]
but I can't do it though but if I were
to imitate what they do it's like I
giggle my way into the [ __ ] it's
different doing there I just love I just
love these nice angled my way into the
[ __ ] just come up with that now you
should make a girl tee that says giggle
my giggle your way into my [ __ ] or
something Oh that'd be great dude
probably cause I have a good sense of
humor yeah the only problem is it takes
like six months so there's a time frame
you know like these other guys that it's
quick right eh and the Google hahahaha
you're a good friend I'm like no I'm not
a friend I'm trying to [ __ ] you the
friends game your [ __ ] and six months
later I have Muriel nice love story this
new study pulled married people and it
found out that all on average it took
them a hundred and seventy two days to
decide that they wanted to get hitch
which is about six months hitched oh I
like that
that's quite a fire ball okay I get that
well how big is a study group three
people see that's not quantified okay
there yeah that's true it's gotta be a
it's gonna be a good sample size well
this other one says that I was on two
thousand coupled and uncoupled people
they found out how long it takes for
people to make decisions and that turned
out to be 210 days so on average it took
six months for people to get married
I gotta myself no the the people to make
decisions it says that it took five bad
interactions before they realize that
they just like someone oh dislike their
like someone it takes five for the
marriage thing it took six months to
realize that they want to get married
they didn't tell me how many people
though yeah I do know that living in LA
is a bit of a bubble because the rest of
the nation people get married much
earlier and then they do make those
decisions much earlier so statistically
this might be true but I I kind of feel
like no I think they're just saying
though that like within those six months
you'll you already know like okay I can
see me going like I can see a future
with this person necessarily them
getting married damn that's crazy
no no that that's when they decide oh I
thought there that's like when they got
married
cuz I'm like three months or so at
dating oh when you go back and they
asked like oh how far into the
relationship did you know that you
wanted to marry this person how did you
know that your moment when you're like I
could marry this woman I didn't like the
first three months we first got together
um weird me and Joe were like we're just
trying to revive JK after we took like a
year off and so we have I think like
maybe 20,000 subscribers and we're only
getting maybe like 8,000 views and we're
like what are we gonna do and then so
I'm like we gotta hit this hard like
full-time and at that time she was a
working professional and she was like
hey you know what if this is really your
passion if this is what you want to do
I'll support you
it's all like oh [ __ ] I'll cut off my
fingers for you then what a down-ass
[ __ ]
that's just like I'll support you if
that's what you want to do like that's
awesome cut off your fingers damn I know
you was down like that ha ha ha oh man
you were down as [ __ ] boot up Oh
what's up hey that's tight man what
about you similar to that actually so
for me was about six months Casey and I
were dating for six months and at that
time I was going through a lot of issues
where it led to the point where I don't
really have anywhere to live and then
Katie rescued me like a dog
me and is not like a dog what the [ __ ]
I'm sorry like a puppy like a cat like a
los iguanas like my job was cutting my
hours so I was getting paid less so I
couldn't afford getting an apartment on
my own at the same time he was moving
out with his roommate getting his own
apartment and he was like well I have
this apartment once you live with me and
I'm like wait we've only been together
for six months and it was like yeah I
know it's a big decision but I thought
about it but I love you and I love you
yes I love you of course
yeah by then we're already oh that was
the first time if it was dude that
[ __ ] what a great moment too soon
we're having like two weeks you really
love me yeah I was like two weeks yeah
this was weird weird she's a lovable
person what the [ __ ] thank you no yeah
he was drinking it sound like oh yeah ya
know when it's drinking that's that's
one of the most honest so he was in
Dallas with his family when he did when
he said that he was drinking then we're
on talking on the phone and then when he
came back I was like you know you said
that he was like I did and then he
thought about it and then I was like
look it's okay we're not that serious
yet you can run I got a lot of baggage I
understand dad you [ __ ] negative dude
you should have left it's better than
him finding out later for sure
I wasn't deceitful carfax out there
that's good
[Music]
I'm a [ __ ] lemon okay [ __ ] lemon
flower give a [ __ ] fresca he knew I was
a diamond okay I know I'm overdue on my
oil change I do mean I love you oh
that's a sweet story have you ever had
[ __ ] car trouble was when the stuff
that you're afraid to say Camaro that I
that I that I think I could marry you're
like probably four or five months in I
didn't say that I wanted to marry I said
you could be somebody that could see
myself with what does she said so
romantic I was she blushed no she got
scared you know she started to serious
you're coming on too strong
yeah for her I mean I didn't tell her
that I wanted to marry her I said I
could I can see myself being here for a
very long time and I think that scared
her a little bit oh really you know
she's very like I wouldn't have gotten
scared if I really like the person yeah
yeah but for her everything was such a
new experience because I am her she was
my longest relationship too but for me I
think I was more concrete in who I was
as a person that she was so for me if I
say that I was like oh it's just a
matter of fact like ice that's how I
feel in this moment and so for her it
was more like oh [ __ ] this is like a big
deal but the means my life you know who
you are you know what you like you know
what you want yeah and look at that four
years we still together baby what's that
I'm saying give him my way right in
today being in relationships yeah like I
didn't even think I would ever be in a
relationship ever because at the time
that I was that I met Jess I was like I
just kind of lost hope really that I
would find a partner that will connect
in a genuine way with me because of how
different I am so it's very difficult to
have somebody really understand me and
me them so I'm like well it's easier to
just [ __ ]
[Laughter]
dropping catchphrases like all over no
but then like it was really joke because
I didn't even picture myself doing like
a long-distance thing or investing so
much time and an effort into someone so
far away that I didn't even know but the
connection that we had was so [ __ ]
dope but you know like I think I came
from a place that was so low out like
marriage was like way beyond the realm
of reality for me so it wasn't even on
my mind yeah but just having somebody
that I connected with was such a
refreshing feeling that it was like baby
steps you know it started working and
then we're moving in and like and then
we're talking about now future kids and
all this stuff and it's crazy when did
that happen
no like I see myself with the future
with her you know like I don't talk
about it openly we do we have these
private conversations but yeah you know
me like I'm either came farm wages it's
yeah I told her - I want a romantic farm
with you
she was what about what she wants she is
a very easy easy to go in person wise
thing like I said before you know she's
gonna get our house with her beautiful
servants buff dudes that were nothing
but that's exactly the neckties yeah and
I'm gonna get my mud hut in my Pig
outside and we good
[Music]